I don't have an orichalcum ring. It was
beautiful and
seemed to have power, so I brought it with the intention of giving it to Mr. Nishimura as a present.
But why would I give it to him? It's
orichalcum, and it cost 120 yen.
Maybe Mr. Kasahara is looking for this?  That's it,
Kasahara-san. I did
n't say I'd
give it back. I picked up that ring, so it's mine now.
[Music] I was going to
give it to you, but I'm really good at it, so
[Music] I
guess it's to Mr. Nishimura.  There's no way a ring like this would suit you.
Even though you're a Shinigami, it's certainly a toy ring. It's
low grade and doesn't suit Mr. Nishimura. Maybe that's not true,
Takada-kun. You're always different. It
doesn't suit Mr. Nishimura. That's right.
To Mr. Nishimura.  I'm telling you it doesn't suit me.The toy
ring is clogged.I
asked Nishimura-san to get a proper ring.But I'm
sorry, Nishimura-san.I had other rings, but I'm
still a child, so I
can only prepare a toy ring.  By the
way, that's a
dark matter ring. It's
dark magic in Kyushu, so I
think it would suit Nishimura-san better than orichalcum. Thank you.
Kasahara-san and others also thank you for your advice. I
haven't healed myself, and I'm
still a child, so I can only prepare a toy ring. A
toy would be
enough.  I
'm happy, but I've
found a treasure
[Music]